hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
hallo ich bin auch der wolf heute stimmt
auch wieder mit dabei genau heute gibt
es kartoffeln aus dem ofen und zwar so
kartoffelecken matches aber nicht ganz
normal nicht klassisch sondern mit
parmesan
wir haben das ja mal in hamburg gegessen
beim dreh mit technik niemand genau
und da muss da muss richtig lecker und
deswegen habe ich ja kommen aber es war
auch pommes drauf und es war wirklich
super lecker mit vielen gewürzen und hat
gedacht was machen wir jetzt mit
ofenkartoffeln und den matches und da
kommt dann eben auch parmesan mit
viele kenne ich vielleicht aus von denen
von diesem podcast wo dann rum fahren
was verkauft ja ich habe beides essen
und füßen ist nicht mit füßen zu tun
wir sind zu wissen diese wiese wegen die
energie sparen und richtig tolle speisen
machen ja streetfood genau streetfood ja
heute ist das eigentlich auch so ein
rezept oder genau kann man auch gut aus
der hand essen in so einem kleinen
schwätzchen finde ich echt super aber
ich denke ich jetzt mal die zutaten und
zwar brauche ich dafür kartoffeln diese
sind jetzt mittelgroß und die sind
mehlig kochend und davon brauche ich
etwa 12 bis 16 stück je nach hunger eine
teelöffel pfeffer denn mal ich gleich
fisch ich habe ich einen teelöffel
paprikapulver ist es süß zwei teelöffel
thymian getrocknet einen teelöffel salz
und halben teelöffel curry 100
milliliter olivenöl und parmesan also
parmesan habe ich jetzt am stück und das
sollte man auch immer am stück kaufen
weil da eben keine trennmittel drin sind
wie beim geriebenen parmesan genau am
stück und ich hab immer den termin nicht
aussprechen aber ich nehme den genau
jedenfalls nehme ich jetzt erst einmal
die kartoffeln die muss ich jetzt noch
waschen
das habe ich eben vergessen
das hat deswegen welches weil sich
gestellt sind
mit sünde die kartoffeln und halbiert
sie und dann schneide ich sie in ecken
und zwar mache ich das immer so dass ich
von der mitte ausgehe und nach außen
scheint aber dann ziehen sie einfach am
schönsten aus nur so als rand info die
kartoffel sind aus der pfalz hast du
gesagt was sie kochen sind
ich habe mich verschluckt wie du sagst
du sowas vor der kamera es schauen
millionen von menschen zu ich hab das
comeback angetrunken von bucher diese
dieser t
die kartoffeln geschnitten und ich kann
die marinade vorbereiten
dafür gebe ich jetzt die gewürze in eine
große schüssel mit rein und pfeffer wird
die zutaten gut mit dem schneebesen
verrühren
da gebe ich jetzt wie kartoffeln mit
rein und vermische sie dann mit den
händen ganz gut so große kataloge ja es
war eigentlich kleine mit oder somit die
große kartoffel
zwar muss ich sagen es war ein dummer
bauer christoph mir die fans machte
sieht so animalisch aus was ist das halt
animalis so einfach mit den händen
ja ich bin sonst immer so ganz vornehmen
und man hat aber mit der händler
ich kenne jetzt entweder die kartoffeln
direkt backen oder ihr lasst noch ein
bisschen durchziehen
ich werde seinen deckel drauf geben dann
stelle ich den kühlschrank für etwa eine
halbe stunde und mache in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die soße ich
werde noch den djp zubereiten und zwar
mache ich einen ingwer curry tipp ihr
könnt es beispielsweise auch aber nur
eine sauerei
dazu reichen oder auch selbst gemachten
ketchup aber ich habe mich jetzt wieder
irgendwie kreativ entschieden weil
irgendwie ja so eine richtig schöne
schärfe hat und es passt dann wirklich
sehr gute den ofen kathol zeige euch
noch kurz die zutaten ich brauche dafür
200 gramm schwand oder saure sahne einen
halben teelöffel salz einen teelöffel
kari etwas pfeffer eine knoblauchzehe
einen esslöffel zitronensaft etwas
ingwer so etwa 20 gramm und etwas
aprikosenmarmelade das ist jetzt ein
esslöffel nämlich direkt im schmerz oder
kombiniert die gewürze mit reinen
soziales und kaffee dann mit pfeffer
abschmecken
die knoblauchzehe reichlich dann fein
dann nehme ich den ingwer da wird jetzt
auch fein gerieben und ich habe immer
ein bisschen irgendwo auch im
gefrierfach da ist jetzt auch aus dem
gefrierfach aber man kann ihn trotzdem
direkt gefroren verwenden
ich muss ich die schale noch bequem und
zwar mache ich das immer mit einem
löffel schreibt die dann so ein bisschen
ab vor allem an diesen harten stellen
und der rest kann ich dranbleiben
jetzt kommt noch einen esslöffel
zitronensaft mit dazu und dann noch ein
bisschen aprikosenmarmelade die gibt so
ein bisschen je frucht noch mit rein und
da könnt ihr jetzt abschmecken hatte je
nachdem wie süß ihr das haben möchte
gibt ihr entweder den ganzen esslöffel
betreibt oder nur ein bisschen und ich
probiert dann immer ersten bislang und
dann gebe ich noch etwas dazu und
brauche dem gipfel ich jetzt um und
steckte ihn ab und da kommt er in den
kühlschrank und in der zeit kann ich
dann die kartoffelspalten in den ofen
schieben zum backen der kartoffeln nehme
ich jetzt hier die tochter backblech
denn darauf werden sie echt richtig
knusprig aber dazwischen kommen jetzt
noch eine bank folie oder ein backpapier
zb mag folie nämlich immer gerne weil
man die halt öfter verwenden kann auch
nicht wegschmeißen muss und da kommen
jetzt die kartoffeln alle schön drauf
und ihr solltet darauf aufpassen dass
sie nebeneinander und nicht übereinander
das restliche öl verteilt jetzt über den
kartoffeln und die wirte arbeitsfläche
und dann kommen die kartoffeln in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 200 grad ober
unterhitze für ungefähr 30 minuten also
je nach dem wie ein backofen backen wie
groß oder klein die kartoffeln
geschnitten habt müssen sie jetzt drin
bleiben
ich werde dann mit der gabel nämlich
testen ob sie durch sind also wenn sie
weich sind und danach kommt später erste
frau sein drum
die kartoffeln sehen wenn wir jetzt nach
30 minuten genauso aus also richtig gut
und wenn man mit der gabel rein stich
sind sie weich also sind sie durch es
kommt noch der parmesan käse drauf und
dann werden sie noch mal fünf minuten
bei der gleichen temperatur weiter
gebracht
die kartoffeln sind jetzt fertig zum rad
steht auch schon bereit und möchte
probieren
ich hab hunger gab der duft hat sich
angela seien gehe jetzt hier in so ein
schönes städtchen und dann kommt doch
noch mal gut parmesan darüber wo es so
lust drauf fragen wie schmeckt noch die
soße die soße die müssen wir mal
wirklich probieren werden so schöne
ständig im kühlschrank und noch ein
bisschen pfeffer
aber ich stelle jetzt schon mal wer wird
schön dick du nicht
ich meine die soße noch frisch
geriebenen pfeffer drüber erste mal am
körper jetzt kannst du probieren
am besten ist es einfach heute abend
hier
wahnsinn
feine übrigens nicht mehr alle
kartoffeln oft schlecht geparkt war ich
ein paar kartoffeln zu viel hatte hab
ich dir einfach in die kader geschmissen
und die waren dann auch richtig lecker
also ehrlich ich konnte
ich habe die gleiche draufgemacht immer
schmeckt und oder editiert
aber ich habe eigentlich zwei minuten
gewartet
das dürfte noch 190 grad was erzählen
sagt zwar genial arbeite zuschauer
fragen uns wer immer nur ich mag es sich
so richtig schön witzig ein bisschen mal
sportlich kein fleisch mehr ohne mit
chef kein fleisch mehr nur noch kathrin
denn im vergleich zum star genial wird
es auch sehr gut falls er das rezept
nach machen wollt dann geht auch blog.de
nach stets noch mal für euch und die
soße finde ich also diesen hippen auch
richtig genial soll machen vorauszusehen
kann strauss schmecken was drin ist
ich weiß nicht ich mich interessiert ist
es gar nicht einfach viel spaß beim
nachbacken bist nachmachen bis zur
nächsten mahlzeit aber das ganze ding
weg zu gehen unsere fotos mal ein buch
blech versuch